WILL GET TO THE BOTTOM OF IT.
>> JOHN SOLOMON JOINING IS NOW
FOX NEWS LEGAL ANALYST ON THE
LEGAL ASPECT OF ALL THIS.
>> THE MOST IMPORTANT THING IN
ANY CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION IS
THE PROSECUTOR IS TO TREAT ALL
CASES THE SAME.
MEANING OF SOMETHING IS
SIMILARLY SITUATED, IT NEEDS TO
BE TREATED WITH UNIFORMITY.
CLEARLY WE KNOW THAT DID NOT
HAPPEN HERE.
IT'S ARTIE BEEN ESTABLISHED.
AS YOU SAID PRESIDENT TRUMP HAV
THE POWER TO DECLASSIFY JOE
BIDEN NEVER DID.
MOREOVER THE DOCUMENTS THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP TOOK WENT FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE AND THE A SECUR
PLACE IN THE COUNTRY TOMORROW
LAGO ONE OF THEM A SECURE PLACE
IN THE COUNTRY GUARDED
CONSTANTLY BY SECRET SERVICE.
JOE BIDEN'S DOCUMENTS WE HAVE N
IDEA WHERE THEY FLOATED AROUND
FOR AT LEAST A YEAR BEFORE SOME
WENT TO THE BIDEN PENN CENTER
BEFORE SOME WENT TO MS. HOUSE I
DELAWARE.
THE PLAYBOOKS ALREADY BEEN
WRITTEN BY MERRICK GARLAND.
IF YOU WANT TO TREAT THEM WITH
UNIFORMITY, DO THE SEARCH
WARRANT AT ALL THE BIDEN
RESIDENCE IS A A.
OF THAT'S IMPORTANT.
INTERVIEW ANYONE COULD'VE
TOUCHED THOSE DOCUMENTS
INCLUDING THE CHINESE WHO WANTE
KEYS AND PAID MILLIONS TO HUNTE
BIDEN.
HUNTER BIDEN SAYS THAT HIS
RESIDENCE HE CAN HIT A GARAGE
DOOR BUTTON TO BE INTERVIEWED.
>> THE AMOUNT OF MONEY GREG
JARRETT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT IS
BREATHTAKING.
MERRICK GARLAND SAT ON THAT NEWS
.
NOW WE HAVE NOT ONE NOT TWO BUT
THREE SEPARATE LOCATIONS WERE
FOUND.
ABOUT THE MONEY IS THE MOST
DISTURBING.
THE MONEY TO THE PENN BIDEN
CENTER THE OVERWHELMING MAJORIT
OF IT CAME WHEN BIDEN WAS THERE.
HE WAS BEING PAID BY THE
UNIVERSITY.
THE UNIVERSITY HAD THEIR
PROFESSORS REQUEST FROM MERRICK
GARLAND THAT THEY DROPPED THE
ESPIONAGE CASE WITH CHINA.
HE DROPPED IT.
I AM OR MEET ABOUT EVERYTHING
I'M READING.
>> IT LOOKS LIKE A QUID PRO QUO
WHERE THE EQUIVALENT OF A
BRIBERY.
JOE BIDEN IS THE NEW BRITNEY
SPEARS IT OOPS, I DID IT AGAIN.
AND AGAIN.
THREE DIFFERENT LOCATIONS WITH
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION IN IT.
YOU CAN MAYBE RATIONALIZE IT WA
INADVERTENT ONCE.
MAY BE ACCIDENTAL TWICE A.
OF THREE TIMES?
REMEMBER THE CRIMINAL STATUTE
SAYS THE STORY REMOVAL AND STOR
OF CLASSIFIED INFORMATION IS A
CRIME IF IT'S EITHER INTENTIONA
OR RECKLESS.
THIS NOW APPEARS TO BE THE
DEFINITION OF RECKLESSNESS UNDE
THE CRIMINAL STATUTE.
JOE BIDEN IS AT GREATER RISK OF
DONALD TRUMP BECAUSE TROMP AS A
FORMER PRESIDENT SAYS HE
DECLASSIFY THE DOCUMENTS BEFORE
HE LEFT OFFICE.
JOE BIDEN DOESN'T HAVE THAT
DEFENSE AVAILABLE AS VICE
PRESIDENT.
IN HIS DEFENSE TODAY, I'VE BEEN
A LAWYER FOR MORE THAN 40 YEARS
I WAS A DEFENSE LAWYER I THINK
I'VE HEARD EVERY EXCUSE IN THE
BOOK.
TODAY HE HEARD A NEW ONE.
IT'S THE CORVETTE DEFENSE.
IT'S OKAY TO HAVE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS BECAUSE I'M SITTING
NEXT TO MY CORVETTE.
>> DOES THAT LOOK LOCKED TO YOUR
?
THERE'S A PICTURE RIGHT THERE.
HOW MANY PEOPLE HAD ACCESS TO
THAT THAT DIDN'T HAVE SECURITY
CLEARANCE?
THEY WON'T GIVE US THE VISITOR
LOGS.
JOE BIDEN IS AT GREATER RISK OF
DONALD TRUMP.
>> BY THE WAY AS A BAD CHOICE O
CORVETTES HE CAN KEEP ITS
TEARING OUT AT THE VISIO SIX IF